[Música]
Hola son las 8 de la noche en Bogotá
quito y lima y las diez en Buenos Aires
y en Montevideo soy Santiago aristian y
les doy la bienvenida a esta segunda
hora de información en directo América
edición nocturna Estos son algunos de
los hechos más destacados de la jornada
posturas cruzadas en la comunidad
internacional sobre el envío de
municiones de racimo a Ucrania Estados
Unidos confirmó que enviará este tipo de
artillería ayer pero la medida genera
polémica y es rechazada por países como
Alemania que firmaron la convención
sobre dichas municiones que prohíbe su
uso por el riesgo para los civiles
las autoridades de Guatemala deben
respetar los resultados de las
elecciones generales celebradas el 25 de
junio esto señalaron hoy desde Human
Rights la organización asegura que los
perdedores buscan obtener resultados que
no lograron en las urnas el tribunal
electoral dice que aún no hay fecha para
oficializar resultados tendremos
análisis en esta emisión
y se cumplen dos años del magnicidio de
hecho en el mohís Quien fuera presidente
de Haití la investigación permanece
estancada y no se realizó ningún juicio
dos años después del magnicidio el país
sigue sumido en un sin número de crisis
y la inseguridad ha ido en aumento
Hoy estamos de estreno en directo a
América edición nocturna a partir de hoy
y todos los viernes tendremos Crónica de
cultura en este Debut Alba Santana
abordará los estrenos del cine del
viernes Como por ejemplo la película
vesper Una distopía de ciencia ficción o
en la región la trágicomedia Argentina
Blondie No se pierdan esta primera
Crónica de cultura
el deportes vamos a hablar de los juegos
centroamericanos y del caribe la
ciclista Mariana pajón se quedó con el
oro en la prueba de BMX diputada este
viernes Luis Méndez Zurich nos cuenta
que es la tercera medalla en este tipo
de justas para la llamada reina del BMX
[Música]
[Aplausos]
segundo bloque es directo a América
edición en nocturna Recuerden que
ustedes pueden participar con el hashtag
directo América f24 dejen sus
comentarios sus preguntas también pueden
proponer temas que quieran que abordemos
vamos a estar leyendo los comenzamos ya
mismo con información vinculada a la
guerra en Ucrania Estados Unidos
finalmente confirmó que enviará
municiones de racismo aquí a pesar de
riesgo humanitario que esto representa
recordemos que en el año 2008 más de 100
países firmaron la convención sobre este
tipo de municiones que prohíbe su uso
Estados Unidos Rusia y Ucrania no
estaban entre ellos y la administración
de Joe biden aprobó este envío como
parte de un nuevo paquete de ayuda
Aunque hay mandatario señaló que la
decisión fue difícil más detalles con el
informe siguiente
un arma controvertida y muy tímida que
será suministrada a Ucrania por Estados
Unidos es lo que confirmó este viernes
el asesor de seguridad nacional
estadounidense Jackson a pesar de sus
posibles efectos humanitarios
devastadores
reconocemos que las municiones en racimo
Crean un riesgo de daños a la población
civil debido a las municiones sin
detonar por eso Hemos aplazado la
decisión lo que se ha podido pero
también existe un riesgo masivo de daño
civil si las tropas y los tanques rusos
pasan por encima de las posiciones
ucranianas toman más territorio
ucraniano y subyugan a más civiles
porque Ucrania no tiene suficiente
artillería las bombas de racimo ya están
siendo utilizadas tanto por las fuerzas
rusas como por las fuerzas ucranianas en
la guerra son cohetes que dispersan
múltiples pequeños explosivos en un
amplio rayo y dejan tras de sí pequeñas
bombas sin explotar lo que supone una
amenaza para la población civil durante
años causando muertes y mutilaciones
Naciones Unidas han pedido a Rusia y
Ucrania que dejen de utilizar municiones
de racimo más de 100 países firmaron una
convención que prohíbe estas bombas
el secretario general apoya la
convención sobre municiones de racimo
que como saben se adoptó hace 15 años y
quiere que los países cumplan los
términos de esa convención y como
resultado por supuesto no quiere que se
sigan utilizando municiones de racimo en
el campo de batalla
Estados Unidos afirma que solo en yara
municiones de Última Generación con un
menor porcentaje de bombas caídas es
decir que no explotan por su parte
Ucrania acogió con satisfacción la
decisión afirmando que necesita Estas
armas para derrotar a Rusia y el
presidente ucraniano
finalizó su viaje por varios países
miembros de la otan y lo hizo en Turquía
donde se juntó con su homólogo receta
Jeep erdoan Estambul fue recibido por el
mandatario Turco en una visita clave
tanto por los intentos de presionar para
el ingreso a la alianza atlántica como
también por el acuerdo de exportación de
granos a través del mar Negro que
finaliza la semana que viene y del cual
ankara es mediador Hernán dijo que
Turquía merece ser miembro de la otan
no hay duda de que Ucrania merece ser
miembro de la otan me gustaría
aprovechar esta oportunidad para
reiterar lo que siempre he defendido
no hay perdedores en una paz justa a
pesar de las diferencias de
entendimiento entre las dos partes es
nuestro sincero deseo que ambas partes
vuelvan a las conversaciones de paz
estamos preparando una cumbre de paz
global y es esencial que Turquía esté
entre los líderes en tal acción también
discutimos hoy los temas críticos de
nuestra cooperación dentro de la otan
particularmente en preparación para la
cumbre en vilda
hay muchas más noticias en directo
América edición nocturna las autoridades
de Guatemala deben respetar los
resultados de las elecciones celebradas
el 25 de junio Esto es lo que señalaron
hoy desde y también la oficina en
Washington para asuntos latinoamericanos
Hola advirtieron además que los
gobiernos interesados deben instar al
gobierno y a otras autoridades a
garantizar los valores democráticos Y
respetar la voluntad de los ciudadanos
de Guatemala manifestada en las urnas
para profundizar en esta información nos
acompaña Ana María Méndez dardón ella es
directora para Centroamérica en walla
Ana María Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en directo a América en France
24 Más allá del pedido que realizaron
recordemos nueve partidos políticos
porque cree usted que se llegó a esa tan
polémica revisión de los votos en
Guatemala y De qué nos habla esa
situación
a ver muy buenas noches es un gusto
acompañarles hoy es sumamente
preocupante lo que ocurre hoy día en
Guatemala
porque una narrativa de fraude
recordemos que cuando es sin fundamento
es una amenaza para la democracia pero
más grave Aún es la judicialización de
un proceso sin reconocer la voluntad
popular y
con ellos se puede Más bien constituir
una violación a la democracia misma
dejar un proceso electoral en el Limbo
es muy grave y creo que lo más dañino
para un proceso electoral es la
incertidumbre
lo que hay detrás pues históricamente
Guatemala ha sido gobernada por grupos
de poder que han sido vinculados a la
corrupción y al crimen organizado y por
primera vez mucho tiempo un candidato
social demócrata logra
incluirse en un segundo lugar para
correr en una segunda la vuelta
electoral
hablaba usted de una amenaza para la
democracia está en riesgo quizás la
segunda vuelta presidencial prevista
para el 20 de agosto
esperemos que no el tribunal supremo
electoral anunció que sí se que se
mantiene la fecha para la segunda vuelta
electoral sin embargo es preocupante que
pese a que ya Se realizaron las
audiencias de revisión y conteo de votos
en las que se reconfirma el resultado
anunciado preliminarmente por el
tribunal supremo electoral el 26
de junio
no se ha confirmado no se han
oficializado los los resultados por
parte del tribunal supremo electoral en
conferencia de prensa hoy la magistrada
del tribunal anunció que estos No pues
no se van a adjudicar los cargos porque
recordemos que se dejaron en suspenso no
solo los resultados a la presidencia
sino también a otros cargos de elección
popular hasta que las Cortes No
certifiquen que ya se cumplió de manera
completa con la instrucción de cotejar
las actas lo cual ya se dio
algunos de los perdedores de las
elecciones en Guatemala están tratando
de abusar del sistema judicial para
obtener los resultados que no pudieron
tener en las boletas Esto es lo que dijo
Juan papier de humans usted suscribe
esta afirmación
Considero que el sistema de justicia en
Guatemala carece de independencia ha
habido un declive democrático en
Guatemala en donde el poder judicial ha
sido penetrado por poderes oscuros que
buscan garantizar impunidad Y creo que
eso ha facilitado que estos partidos
políticos pues utilicen o
instrumentalicen la Justicia con
intereses políticos y para cubrirse de
impunidad en otros casos creo que es
importante mencionar que tanto la misión
de observación electoral de la oea como
la de la Unión Europea manifestaron que
no encontraron pruebas de fraude ni
irregularidades significativas que
pudieran poner en duda el resultado
Entonces es importante que estos
partidos también tuvieron la oportunidad
de
denunciarlo el Día de las elecciones y
no lo hicieron
Ana María Méndez dardor Muchísimas
gracias por su análisis en directo
American France 24 en español gracias a
ustedes Buenas noches hacemos con más
noticias este viernes se cumplen dos
años del magnicidio de giovenelmois
Quien fuera presidente de Haití el
fallecido mandatario perdió la vida
luego de un asalto a su residencia
privada a manos de un grupo de
mercenarios en el país caribeño todavía
no se llevó a cabo ningún juicio por
este caso y la investigación ya pasó por
cinco jueces y permanece sin avances el
informe es de Juan pupiales
un crimen que impactó al mundo 12 fueron
los tiros que recibió givenel Moisés en
su propia residencia el 7 de julio de
2021 su muerte fue recordada este
viernes dos años después por parte del
Primer Ministro Ariel Angie quien
manifestó el que es un sentimiento
latente este magnicidio aún no se ha
resuelto
para el gobierno es importante que echó
en el Moisés encuentre justicia haciendo
todo en mi poder para ayudar al sistema
judicial a ir hacia adelante
dentro de Haití el caso parece que se
estancado no se ha convocado a un juicio
y ya son cinco los jueces que han
asumido la investigación uno de ellos
renunció después de que su asistente
muriera en condiciones confusas más de
40 sospechosos permanecen en una cárcel
de Haití Incluyendo a 18 antiguos
soldados de Colombia acusados del crimen
para Martín La viuda de Moisés la
solución pasa por un tribunal fuera de
su país ante el bloqueo institucional de
los asesinos en el poder hace falta un
tribunal especial internacional
en Estados Unidos se han producido once
arrestos por este magnicidio y uno de
ellos ya fue procesado para la fiscalía
de Florida detrás de la muerte de maíz
Hay un gran complot internacional para
contratar a mercenarios y acabar con su
vida para luego beneficiarse de
cuantiosos contratos de la
Administración venidera